[Music]
hi my name is gordon bass and i'm a
writer and i want to tell you a story
about a man
his name has been carlin
and he drove the oceans of the world in
an amphibious vehicle there was only one
problem the vehicle tended to sink
[Music]
ben carlin met my grandfather in 1947 so
i grew up hearing stories about ben
eventually i became so obsessed with his
adventure that i ended up writing a book
about him ben was born in western
australia he was a smart kid but he
could never shake the feeling that he
had grown up on the very edge of the
world and so as soon as he was able he
wanted to set off and find adventure he
started by mining for gold in western
australia didn't do very well at that
he joined the army and signed up for
bomb disposal in world war ii but he
ended up repairing latrines and runways
so he felt he'd been a failure at that
and finally at the age of 35 he decided
he had one more shot to accomplish
something that would put his name on the
map he decided he was going to circle
the world in an amphibious vehicle
the vehicle in question was an
amphibious version of the world war ii
army jeep so picture an army jeep with a
boat shell around it and that's what it
was
ben found one for 901 and spent the next
year preparing for his journey
he called it the half safe it was
supposed to be good on land and water
but in reality it turned out not to be
so great on either one
in 1948 carlin and his american wife
eleanor set off from halifax nova scotia
the journey was not smooth the entire
cabin was just five feet wide so the
only way to sleep was to curl up on the
back bench seat
the engine was so loud that they just
stopped trying to talk to each other
they hit a gale in the middle of the
atlantic they thought they were going to
die and at that point they realized they
hadn't even packed life jackets
so by the time they got to england they
had to completely rebuild the half safe
they had less than a hundred dollars to
their name so they ended up stopping for
four years eleanor got job and ben spent
a lot of time preparing the next leg of
the journey in 1955 ben and eleanor set
off they thought it would take a year at
most and they would be able to return to
their normal lives have kids and start a
family
when they hit the middle east and they
were driving through syria and iraq then
discovered that he hadn't ventilated the
jeep properly it rose to 170 degrees and
they ended up driving by night and then
sleeping in the shade of the jeep by day
so they could avoid the heat of the sun
there were bandits
and there were some roads that they were
crossing that hadn't been traversed by
vehicles since the middle of world war
ii which was ten years earlier by
calcutta the marriage was over eleanor
had enough and she left
ben continued alone oversea and land for
the rest of the journey when he got to
the states he'd hoped for a movie deal
about his adventure but it never
materialized
in the end on may 13 1958
ben completed the journey he traveled 40
000 miles over land and 10 000 miles
over water
part of the reason that ben never found
lasting fame was that there was no
deeper reason for the journey other than
to prove he could do it
[Music]
this was the era before gps and before
satellite radio and before distress
beacons
so ben was really navigating just by the
stars and he taught himself how to
navigate out of a book that he bought in
a secondhand bookstore
what been accomplished
going around the world in an amphibious
vehicle it set a record that stood for
60 years and not only has the record
stood for 60 years but nobody's even
tried to replicate it which gives you a
sense of the magnitude
[Music]
[Applause]
you